well one consequence of the war in
Ukraine is that Europe is now scrambling
to reduce its dependence on Russian
energy the price of gas was already high
before The Invasion now that Russian
soldiers are in Ukraine prices have
spiked again natural gas now costs 10
times more than at the start of 2021.
gas is still flowing through pipelines
from Russia to customers in Western
Europe but if the Kremlin were to cut
supplies that would cause a shock wave
across the continent one natural gas
pipeline which has never gone online and
probably never will is the nordstream 2
pipeline between Russia and Germany last
week the German government canceled
certification of nordstream 2 a step
that the U.S and other European
countries had wanted for years
my next guest is Benjamin Schmidt he
joins me tonight from Washington D.C
he's a former U.S state Department
advisor on European energy security he's
now with Harvard University Benjamin
it's good to have you I have to admit I
lost count of how many times you and I
have spoken over the years about the
dangers of Nordstrom too you have been
sounding the alarm since day one
how do you feel now
well I I'll tell you Brent um thanks for
bringing that up but it's not time for
looking back on the history of this
unfortunately we can do that in the
future we have to save Ukraine right now
and and the bottom line is yes we have
been warning about the energy security
risks but also the National Security
risks of Nordstrom 2 for years and part
of that is the physical dependency on
the Ukrainian gas transmission Network
in and around the line of conduct
contact in donbos and I've talked to you
and and your viewers on Deutsche Villa a
number of times about that
um and and the point that I was making
is that it would make it very difficult
given in uh given that uh Putin would
still rely on the Ukrainian gas
transmission Network in the absence of
nordstream tube to push out from the
line of contact in donbos given the
physical proximity of those pipes that
they still rely on to get gas to Europe
uh um from where the fighting was the
thing that was missing in that analysis
and I don't think anyone was
anticipating is a full-scale war across
the entirety of Ukraine
um and and that and is uh that is very
very troubling indeed obviously
um and and my heart goes out to all of
my friends and colleagues uh that I've
met over the years that are are still in
Ukraine
um but we need more actions not just
thoughts and prayers we need to bring
more military aid in the form of of
stingers and javelins uh and and uh
drones uh Turkish drones I believe are
are the uh the most compatible at this
point uh but also take a vital energy
security steps and on Nordstrom too look
what we've seen over the past week is
basically Berlin doing every single
topic that you and I have discussed over
the years number one was certification
of Nordstrom 2 was halted and the way it
was certified is really important and I
want to tell the viewers what's going on
there uh because it's so important so
basically
uh under article 11 of the gas directive
of of the European Union's third energy
package a a a a member State that's
that's vetting the um the energy
security or national security risk of a
piece of energy infrastructure needs to
include if that piece of infrastructure
will harm the energy security of of the
the member State or the Union as a whole
and what um Minister hobek had done is
insert language into the assessment that
the previous government had made that
said it didn't have any energy security
risks which was obviously false uh to
include National Security in there
that's really important because it is a
fundamental sea change finally Berlin
has taken into account that energy
security is National Security and it's
not just a commercial deal has been has
been said over the years yeah [ __ ] man
I want you to listen to what the German
economics Minister said today he was
talking about energy issues and yeah
this is what he said listen
I say this with raise regret and without
any joy that Germany is dependent on
Russian energy
[Music]
we must free ourselves from Russian
energy Imports that includes gas that
includes coal and that includes oil
we're doing everything we can to achieve
that
[Music]
Benjamin you know you know what this
well someone described it to me today as
an energy come to Jesus moment for
Germany but it's taken so long
the signs had been there the whole time
the reality has been there we've finally
got it is it too little too late
uh it can't be too little too late
because it has to take place so we've
seen uh um the the uh the statements by
Chancellor Schultz to take very positive
and very rapid steps to implement
basically what the European Union has
been doing since 2015 is an energy Union
concept to reduce uh dependency on
Russian natural gas in particular so
building LNG terminals to import Global
Supply remember you and I have pointed
out that Russian propaganda that was
stated by many uh German supporters of
Nordstrom 2 was that diversification
infrastructure in in our U.S opposition
in ordering two was quote unquote just
to sell us LNG well look where we're at
right now that is actually what we've
been talking about all the time is
National Security risks of Russian uh uh
actions like this and we've seen
Nordstrom 2 be sanctioned uh the the um
the corporate officers of Nordstrom 2ag
are also sanctioned for mashtazi officer
and Putin criminal is sanctioned and
Nordstrom 2 AG itself was gone uh had
gone bankrupt and has been dissolved all
106 employees have been fired and so I
think that that is the final chapter of
Nordstrom too uh now we need to move
forward on a European basis to build
more floating storage and regasification
units to increase the regassification
capacity to start planning for next
winter we're at the end of the heating
cycle right now in the spring but right
now we need to be taking actions for the
fall and into next winter let me ask you
this before we run out of time you're
right we're coming into spring into
summer here but the fall will it'll be
here sooner than you realize and the
need for natural gas will be with us
again can you imagine the Kremlin then
cutting off those pipelines that are
flowing across Ukraine for example come
next Autumn Nick's winner I mean is that
a risk that we're already running
I think it's a risk we're running right
now today remember they're going through
an active combat zone right now and
frankly heroic ukrainians are still
running that to make sure Europe is kept
warm they're sitting at their control
stations at these gas transmission
system uh operation centers keeping that
gas flowing from Russia through an
active War Zone in Ukraine to European
customers and so there that those steps
need to take place now to diversify we
need to uh see Europeans basically uh uh
kicking uh gas prom ownership out of gas
storages in Western Europe remember
Brent a lot of gas storages in Western
Europe are owned or at least partially
owned by Russian state-controlled gas
prom this is a massive conflict of
interest in a time of national security
crisis we also need to see oil sanctions
come on soon but right now we need to
take a three-phase approach first we
need to continue to see the global uh
energy trade market continue to avoid
Russian Euros prices uh sorry Russian
Euros volumes the Euros prices drop
significant below the global Brent price
uh Benchmark of 18 below print and and
that's going to put immediate pressure
on Vladimir Putin we need to then see
vessel sanctions against The Fleets that
that Russia uses to export these
hydrocarbons and then finally have
coordination on a U.S EU basis and
globally on sectoral sanctions on
Russian oil and gas and this has all got
to happen very quickly we've been
talking about this for years now we have
weeks and Benjamin you you put it into
perspective too people here in Germany
who are depending on natural gas for
Heat have that natural gas thanks to the
ukrainians who are in the middle of a
war Benjamin Schmidt as always thank you
we will be talking again soon I'm sure
thanks
thanks so much Brent